.
>>> NEW OVERNIGHT A POTENTIAL
SIGN OF LIFE AS RESCUERS RACE TO
FIND THE SUBMERSIBLE THAT
VANISHED WHILE DIVING ON THE
"TITANIC" SHIPWRECK.
SONAR PICKED UP BANGING SOUNDS
IN THE SEARCH AREA AND THOSE
WERE REPEATED, THOSE SOUNDS,
EVERY 30 MINUTES ACCORDING TO AN
INTERNAL U.S. GOVERNMENT MEMO.
THIS MORNING THE COAST GUARD
SAYS IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT THE
SOURCE OF THE SOUND WAS AND NAVY
EXPERTS ARE ANALYZING IT.
IT IS ESTIMATED THE FIVE
PASSENGERS HAVE ABOUT A DAY LEFT
OF BREATHABLE AIR AT THIS POINT
IF THAT'S SUBMERSIBLE IS STILL
INTACT.
HERE IS WHAT A FORMER PASSENGER
ONBOARD THAT SAME MISSING SUB
SAID WHAT IT'S LIKE INSIDE.
>> AS YOU START TO DESCEND
THROUGH THE WATER COLUMN IT IS
AN AMAZING JOURNEY TO SEE THE
LIGHT QUICKLY DISAPPEAR AND
WITHIN FIVE, TEN MINUTES YOU ARE
IN PITCH DARK.
COMPLETE DARK.
AND YOU HAVE THE LIGHTS FROM THE
SUB, RIGHT.
YOU HAVE THE LIGHTS FROM THE
SUBMERSIBLE YOU CAN SEE OUTSIDE
AND INTERNALLY.
BUT WITHOUT THOSE, YOUR LIGHT IS
GONE AT ANY DEPTH BELOW A COUPLE
HUNDRED METERS.
SO ANYONE WOULD BE IN COMPLETE
DARKNESS IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE
POWER STILL AT THIS POINT.
>> TAKE A LOOK.
NEW VIDEO FROM THIS MORNING OF
ANOTHER RESCUE VESSEL HEADING
OUT TO JOIN THE OPERATIONS AFTER
THE U.S. AIR FORCE FLEW SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT INTO NEWFOUNDLAND.
MIGUEL MARQUEZ JOINS US IN ST.
JOHN'S, NEWFOUNDLAND.
CAN YOU TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT
THE COAST GUARD IS DOING THIS
MORNING?
>> Reporter: IT IS ALL HANDS ON
DECK.
THERE WAS A COAST GUARD SHIP
FROM THE CANADIAN COAST GUARD
THAT JUST SHIPPED OUT.
NOW THERE IS THE HORIZON ARCTIC
THAT PRIVATE SHIP THAT LEFT
OVERNIGHT.
BOTH OF THEM CARRYING GEAR.
BOTH OF THEM HEADING OUT TO THE
SEARCH AREA NOW IN THE HOPE THAT
THEY CAN RESCUE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY BE AS FAR AS TWO MILES
DOWN AND LOOKING FOR HELP.
WITH REGARD TO THE SOUNDS THAT
WERE HEARD, THIS WAS OVER ABOUT
A FOUR-HOUR PERIOD.
THERE WAS A POSEIDON, A SUB
HUNTER THAT DROPPED BUOYS INTO
THE OCEAN.
IT HEARD BANGING.
EVERY 30 MINUTES THEY HEARD A
REGULAR BANGING.
AND THEN FOUR HOURS LATER THEY
DROPPED MORE BUOYS IN, HEARD
MORE BANGING.
THEY SENT REMOTE OPERATED
VEHICLES TO THE LOCATION WHERE
THEY THOUGHT THAT SOUND WAS
COMING FROM BUT WERE NOT ABLE TO
FIND ANYTHING.
THEY ARE NOW MOVING SURFACE
SHIPS AROUND THE AREA TO SEE IF
THEY CAN EITHER HEAR OTHER
SOUNDS.
THEY HEARD OTHER SOUNDS AFTER
THAT INITIAL PERIOD YESTERDAY OF
ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE HOURS OR SO,
BUT IT WASN'T BANGING.
SO THEY ARE NOT CLEAR, IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHAT THEY WERE HEARING
DOWN THERE AT THAT POINT.
BUT JUST AN EXCRUCIATING WEIGHT.
AN ABSOLUTE CONCERN HERE FOR
WHAT, IF THEY ARE ALIVE, WHAT
THEY MUST BE GOING THROUGH DOWN
THERE IN THE COLD AND THE DARK
AND JUST HOPING AGAINST HOPE
THAT THEY ARE RESCUED.
BACK TO YOU.
>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THE
SEARCH AND THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE INVOLVED.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT ONE SHIP
THAT WAS EN ROUTE SEARCHING FROM
THE AIR, ON THE SURFACE OF THE
WATER, BELOW THE WATER.
MIGUEL, WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> Reporter: SO, THERE WERE
THREE U.S. MILITARY C-17s THAT
LANDED IN ST. JOHN'S IN
NEWFOUNDLAND YESTERDAY.
THAT GEAR WAS OFFLOADED FROM THE
PLANES, PUT ON TO THE HORIZON
ARCTIC THAT WENT OUT ABOUT TWO
HOURS AGO.
AND THERE IS EVERYTHING FROM
REMOTE OPERATED VEHICLES,
SUBMERSIBLES THAT CAN DIVE DOWN
THAT DEEP, GEAR THAT, IF THEY
FIND IT, THEY CAN WENCH IT UP IF
NECESSARY, AND EVEN REMOTE -- OR
DECOMPRESSION CHAMBERS, SO IF
INDIVIDUALS COME UP AND THEY ARE
SUFFERING THE EFFECTS OF
DECOMPRESSION, THEY CAN PUT THEM
IN A CHAMBER AND, HOPEFULLY,
SAVE THEM.
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN DO IT
SEEMS IS BEING DONE.
BACK TO YOU.
>> MIGUEL MARQUEZ IN
NEWFOUNDLAND, THANK YOU.
>> MIGUEL WAS JUST SAYING THIS
IS A HUGE MULTINATIONAL SEARCH
AND RESCUE OPERATION.
IT'S IN THE AIR.
AMERICAN AND CANADIAN
SURVEILLANCE PLANES ARE FLYING
OVERHEAD.
THE CANADIAN P-3 DROPS
TORPEDO-LIKE BUOYS IN THE WATER
ON THE SURFACE.
FIVE VESSELS FROM THE UNITED
STATES, CANADA AND FRANCE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED.
AND SEARCHING UNDERWATER.
THE ROBOT THAT DIVES DEEPER THAN
THE "TITANIC."
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 13,000 PLUS
FEET HERE.
THE SHIP DELIVERING IT IS ONLY
EXPECTED TO ARRIVE TONIGHT.
WE KNOW TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
>> ONLY 24 HOURS ABOUT OF
BREATHABLE AIR INSIDE THAT
VESSEL.
DAVID GALLO IS A SENIOR ADVISOR
FOR THE STRATEGIC INITIATIVES
FOR RMS "TITANIC" INCORPORATED
WHICH OWNS THE SALVAGE RIGHTS TO
THE TITANIC WRECK SITE.TITANIC
THE TITANIC WRECK SITE.
THE LAST UPDATE WAS THE SCOPE
WAS 10,000 SQUARE MILES, ABOUT
THE SIZE OF THE STATE OF
MARYLAND AND THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING THE SIZE OF AN
EXTENDED CAB PICKUP TRUCK,
RIGHT?
SO THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE.
ONCE YOU HEAR THE BANGING, DO
YOU CONCENTRATE ON WHERE THAT
WAS?
OR DO YOU EXPAND BECAUSE THUS
FAR YOU HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING IN
THAT 10,000 SQUARE MILES?
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S A BIG AREA.
BUT THEY MUST HAVE REASONS TO
EXPAND THE SEARCH AREA TO LOOK
THERE.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE THE
AIR SEARCH IN CASE THE SUB IS AT
THE SURFACE.
BUT I THINK IT'S SO -- YOU CAN'T
IGNORE THE BANGING.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TIME TO WAIT
TO ANALYZE THE SOUNDS EXACTLY.
SO YOU HAVE TO ASSUME, I THINK,
THAT THEY ARE HUMAN MADE AND
THEN MOVE EQUIPMENT IN THAT
DIRECTION RIGHT NOW SO THAT IF
THE ANALYSIS HAPPENS AND YOU
SAY, OKAY, THAT'S THE SUB THAT
YOU ARE ALREADY HAVE VEHICLESEN
TH
ON THE SPOT.
THERE IS NO TIME TO WASTE WITH
WAITING TO ANALYZE BEFORE YOU
MOVE THAT WAY.
AND I AM SURE THE COAST GUARD IS
DOING THAT.
THEY ARE MOVING -- IN FACT, I
HEARD THAT.
THEY ARE VECTORING IN ON THAT
AREA.
SO MY HOPE IS THAT THEY DO THAT
QUICKLY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'VE
RESPONDED TO THE BANGING OR
SOUNDS WITH ANOTHER SOUND FROM
THE SURFACE SHIP, FROM A SURFACE
SHIP BACK TO THE SUBMARINE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, YES, WE HEAR YOU.
YOU KNOW, SO THAT'S -- THAT
WILL -- WE WILL HAVE TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE DONE THAT.
>> MAYBE WE WILL FIND OUT AT THE
NEXT UPDATE FROM THE COAST
GUARD.
YOU HAVE A DEAR FRIEND ONBOARD,
P.H. NARGEOLET ONBOARD.
WE ARE HOPING ALONGSIDE YOU THEY
ARE ALL OKAY AND STILL ALIVE.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT ROLE THE
BUOYS DROPPED, THE SHIPS AND
AIRCRAFT CAN ALL PLAY TOGETHER?
>> SURE.
YEAH.
THE AIRCRAFT, SO YOU CAN FLY
OVERHEAD LOOKING DOWN AT THE
SURFACE TO SPOT THINGS, USE
RADAR ALSO TO SPOT THINGS AT THE
SURFACE.
ONCE YOU GET BELOW THE SEA LEVEL
THOUGH, THE WATER LEVEL, YOU'RE
IN A WORLD OF SOUND.
NOT THINGS YOU CAN SEE EASILY,
BUT, YOU KNOW, SOUND TRAVELS A
LONG WAY BENEATH THE WATER.
YOU CAN'T HEAR THAT FROM A PLANE
OVERHEAD, SO THEY DROP THE
TORPEDO-LIKE SONAR BUOYS FROM
THE PLANE INTO THE WATER.
THEY HAVE THE ACOUSTIC
LISTENING.
SO THEY ARE LISTENING TO THE
UNDERWATER WORLD AND THEY TAKE
THE SOUNDS THAT THEY HEAR, VERY
SENSITIVE, AND SEND THEM BACK TO
THE AIRCRAFT FOR ANALYSIS.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY REALLY YOU CAN
HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE DEEP
FROM A PLANE OVERHEAD.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW, TYPICALLY
THESE ARE MADE TO FIND
SUBMARINES AND SUBMARINES DON'T
GO ANYWHERE NEAR -- NAVY
SUBMARINES DON'T GO ANYWHERE
NEAR 3,800 METERS DEPTH.
SO I AM NOT SURE IF THE BUOYS
CAN HEAR THAT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THAT THEY
CAN AT THIS POINT.
TIME IS OUT.
THAT'S THE WORLD SERIES WAY TO
HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON FROM A
PLANE OVERHEAD.
>>> HOPEFULLY, WE GET THOSE
ANSWERS FROM THE COAST GUARD
WHEN THEY GET THEIR UPDATE